another day another protest in Sweda the
people of this province in southern
Syria are angry because of a collapsed
economy and are calling for an end to
president Bashar al-assad's rule
[Music]
for 12 years we endured a difficult and
disgraceful life the state has been
robbed I ask you Bashar al-assad when
will the people of Syria be able to live
in dignity
these have been the biggest protests and
government-held territories since Assad
and his allies were able to recapture
much of the country from the opposition
and they are now in their second months
but so far they aren't seen as a threat
to the regime and others in other
government-controlled territories have
been stifled it was an attempt to
protest in different areas in Syria's
north south east west but how the regime
dealt with these a protests is the the
different thing and some in some areas
the regime had an immediate security
reaction
that hasn't happened in Sweda the
response of the authorities to the
non-violent demonstrations has been
restrained unlike in 2011 when similar
protests led to a harsh Crackdown people
here are from the minority Drew's
Community they are armed and unlike in
the past the community's religious
leaders are behind the movement
our movement is
people here say they know they can't
topple the leadership but they want to
show it is no longer tenable
they deny their movement is about
separatism they carry historic symbols
of national unity and the struggle for
freedom
those living in coastal cities I tell
you they don't have fear
loud voices and if you can because of
bashar's thugs come to Sweda where you
can speak freely
[Applause]
The Province enjoys limited autonomy
because it largely isolated itself from
the war ignoring the protests appears to
be a strategy on the part of the
authorities at least for now